alors on va parler euh d'un autre
déplacement la tezy le petit véhicule
électrique de Renault est en autopartage
sur l'agglomération cinquantinoise
depuis ce mardi c'est une première en
France et une agence de location est
ouverte en gare de Saint-Quentin nous y
étions à peine ouvert qu'ils font la
queue devant la porte la tzie en
autopartage arrive sur la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Eveline et
sduit déjà les futurs utilisateurs j'ai
beaucoup d'amis qui sont dans dans la
ville mais pas très proche de chez chez
moi bah ça me permettrait d'aller voir
d'aller les voir plus rapidement c'est
pas trop cher financièrement parlant et
voilà quoi pour 29 centimes par minute
c'est pratique si on fait qu'un trajet
de 2 3 minutes fa au lieu de prendre le
bus et payer 1,90 € pour réserver votre
twezy rendez-vous sur Internet ou sur
votre smartphone pour vérifier la
disponibilité et le taux de charge des
véhicules l'autre façon plus direct
cette fois vous rendre sur une zone de
garage Ty sur les communes de
guillancour Montini voisin et Trapp et
muni de votre badge débloquez la voiture
pas d'abonnement seulement des frais
d'adhésion de 15 € pour obtenir votre
pass tzy on ne paye que lors de
l'utilisation lorsque je roule là je
suis à 29 centimes la minute plafonné à
11,9 de l'heure si je suis en arrêt
temporaire comme là c'està-dire que
personne d'autre que moi ne peut
l'utiliser mais il est en stationnement
à ce moment-là je suis à 10 centimes la
minute et puis en plus si je veux le
réserver j'ai un for fait réservation de
1 € pour 15 minutes de réservation les 5
premières minutes sont gratuites après
le passage du badge sur le Code Bar et
pour ce service d'autopartage il faut
être titulaire d'un permis voiture
depuis plus de 2
[Musique]
ans alors la fameuse twezy le petit
véhicule électrique je dis petit
véhicule c'est pas ça va ça n'est pas
péjure actif je sa pas comment on sait
pas comment l'appeler hein vous allez
nous dire commenta quadricycle ah un
quadricycle alors le fameux petit
quadricycle électrique de Renault est en
autopartage sur l'agglomération
cquantinois c'est une première en France
Corine paquet bonsoir vous êtes chef de
projet Renault et Laurent ch bonsoir
vous représentez la communauté
deagglomération de de Saint-Quentin
alors je l'ai dit c'est une une première
en France oui tout à fait nous avons
choisi de faire la première
expérimentation à côté de notre
Technocentre de Guy encour et la
première est aujourd'hui effectivement
nous ouvrons le service depuis midi
aujourd'hui voilà donc on a vu le sujet
dans l'agence de location peut venir se
renseigner en gare de Saint-Quentin en
attendant ça c'est une agence Provis
attendant une belle agence une belle
agence dans la Salle des pas perdu qui
existe déjà d'ailleurs et qui n'attend
que l'ouverture de la d'accord alors
vous dites c'est une première malgré
tout depuis le mois de juin il y a eu
des clients testeurs donc ça veut dire
que ça a bien fonctionné tout à fait
nous avons depuis le 21 juin nous avons
200 clients qui ont testé le service qui
ont pu l'apprécier et qui nous ont fait
des retours et qui ce qui nous permet
d'ouvrir aujourd'hui à l'ensemble de la
population alors je disais j'avais un
peu de mal à préciser ce que pouvait
être la tzy c'était c'est pas vraiment
une voiture et vous avez dit
effectivement c'est un quadr quadcycle
rappelle un petit peu on peut être à
combien dans cette voitureà tout à fait
donc c'est une voiture deux places qui
est parfaitement adaptée à la ville deux
places l'une derrière l'autre on peut se
mettre deux adultes d'ailleurs monsieur
shener ici présent a été l'arrière du
paqu monsieur cher on va pas donner vos
mon sur vous êtes particulièrement grand
c'est ça voilà et il a il a il a été à
l'arrière du tzy je lui ai fait faire un
tour à l'arrière du tzy il est rentré
parfaitement ça pas être facile pour les
genoux non ça c'est bien passé c'était
la deuxè placefortable alors combien de
T aujourd'hui à disposition et
concrètement expliqu nous voilà on est
intéressé comment on fait voilà donc il
y a une cinquantaine de twezy à
disposition sur le territoire donc si si
on est intéressé il faut aller sur le
site internet
wwteway.com là vous aurez voilà vous
aurez tous les renseignements
nécessaires pour pour adhérer au service
vous pouvez faire une préinscription et
ensuite vous vous rendez à la boutique
il faut impérativement se rendre à la
boutique si vous ne voulez pas faire une
pré-inscription la la commerciale dans
la boutique s'occupera de vous il y a
pas de problème mais il faut un permis
faut un permis voilà un permis B depuis
de validé depuis 2 ans pour pas avoir le
a à mettre à l'arrière du Ty voilà vous
venez avec votre pièce d'identité et vos
coordonnées de carte bancaire d'accord
et ça coûte combien ça coûte 15 € de
s'inscrire voilà on s'incr 15 € pour
toujours voilà on a un petit badge qui
est marqué tway un badge blanc qui vous
permet d'accéder au à tous les tizis qui
sont sur le territoire lorsque vous le
souhaitez d'accord donc on paye 15 € et
et ensuite uniquement la consommation ce
qui fait que si par exemple vous partez
un mois en vacances vous n'avez pas à
payer donc c'est c'est vraiment un
système de de liberté totale alors et
une fois voilà vous allez me dire
comment je vais trouver les tweezy et
ben non non d'abord je vais vous
demander combien ça coûte moi je suis
branché argent pour l'instant ah bah oui
oui après expliquer où est-ce qu'on va
chercher les twey mais mais en gros
combien ça coûte quand je fais rouler ma
twezy et quand j'arrête ma tezie par
c'est pas le même tarif exactement donc
quand vous quand vous roulez c'est 29
centimes la minute d'utilisation lorsque
vous faites un arrêt la voiture vous
parle en fait la tzy est très
intelligente elle vous parle vous pose
des questions vous répondez par ou non
vous avez des petits boutons et elle
peut vous demander si vous voulez faire
un arrêt temporaire par exemple pour
faire une course et conserver le
véhicule pour vous h à ce momentl si
vous dites oui vous nêes facture que 10
centimes la minute d'ation vite vite
faire ses courses après on peut
récupérer la on peut récupérer la T et
lorsqu'on repart de nouveau on est
tarifé à 29 centimes la minute d'accord
et alors donc on les trouve où ces
fameuses t parce qu'on les voit circuler
dans l'agglomération voilà alors cette
elles sont réparties sur l'ensemble des
communes de voisin Montini aiguill en
courour plus quelques rues de trappe aux
alentours de la gare voilà donc vous les
trouvez partout sur le territoire vous
pouvez les garer n'importe où bien sûr
sur des plac autorisé hein pas sur des
terrespins il faut être il faut
respecter n'importe où y compris sur les
places payantes parce que Renault paye
des redevances en fait au maie ah oui ça
c'est important donc on paye pas le
station voilà on ne paye pas le
stationnement c'est-à-dire quand on a
payé les 15 € et puis qu'on paye
l'utilisation tout est compris la
location la recharge je vous
l'expliquerai tout à l'heure donc elle
elle est à la charge de Renault et le
stationnement aussi donc tout est
compris c'est donc alors concrètement
euh j'ai sur mon smartphone le lieu où
se trouve la T que voilà vous avez la
carte avec toutes les tisies vous pouvez
donc je vais jusqu'à ma t voilà vous
pouvez soit si vous voyez que la tzie
est à deux rues et vous n'avez pas envie
par exemple que Monsieur en face
monsieur cher qui est aussi un adhérent
service la prenne vous pouvez la
préréserver pour 1 € dans ce cas elle
vous est bloqué et quand vous arrivez
vous prenez le véhicule vous passez le
badge et vous pouvez partir d'accord
autre solution vous trouvez des une
voiture dans la rue vous voyez en fait
nous avons un lecteur de badge en haut à
droite du pare-brise qui clignote bleu
s'il clignotte bleu ça veut dire que la
voiture est disponible dans ce cas vous
scannez avec un QR code avec votre
smartphone vous reconnait puis vous
passez votre badge ça vous fait une
double sécurité et vous pouvez partir on
roule avec sa quizy on va faire satite
course on revient on la met où vous la
mettez n'importe où c'est pas comme
libre pas du tout vous n'avez pas à
attendre que qu'une station soit libre
au contraire c'est la liberté totale
vous pouvez la mettre en bas de chez
vous dans les dans les trois villes
voilà dans les trois villes en question
plus dans les quelques rues de trappe
vous la mettez partout dans la rue bien
sûr pas pas à l'intérieur de votre
propriété bien entendu puisque c'est un
service alors autre question parce que
notamment ça me concerne si on n pas de
smartphone alors si vous n'avez pas de
smartphone
ben pour le moment c'est pas c'est pas
l'idéal parce que évidemment le
smartphone permet de voir en permanence
où se trouvent les voitures mais vous
pouvez tout de même utiliser le le
service vous allez sur le site internet
vous voyez où se trouve le véhicule vous
le prééservez puis vous y allez vous le
prenez donc ce n'est pas non non on n
pas obligé d'avoir un smartphone mais
c'est beaucoup plus simple quand même
d'utilisation alors au niveau du du du
tarif vous avez 29 centimes la minute
quand elle roule 10 centimes quand elle
est à l'arrêt est-ce que c'est des prix
par exemple ont été calqués sur autolip
parce que c'est un peu la référence
qu'on a auourioui tout à fait on se
trouve même légèrement inférieur à
hutolip quand quand on regarde
l'ensemble parce qu'on dit 29 centimes
la minute mais en fait on est plafonné à
11,90 de l'heure c'est-à-dire qu'arrivé
à 41 minutes pour être précis on le le
tarif se bloque voilà donc la personne
qui fait 1 heure de trajet ça lui
revient à 11,90 en autonomie on peut
faire combien de temps avec le en
autonomie en fait l'autonomie est à peu
près entre 80 et 100 km d'accord ah oui
ça se calcule pas en temps ça se Calc en
kilom comment l'agglomération c'est
inséré dans ce dans ce projet alors
qu'est-ce qui vous a séduit qu'est-ce
qui nous a séduit B d'abord c'est un
c'est renoué sur notre territoire donc
on a un partenariat on se on se connait
on se rend compte et puis bah nous on
est sur 50 an Liv on est toujours un
petit peu à la recherche de ce de ce
type de
projet surtout qui qui répond sur le
volet transport sur sur sur des des
mobilités qui sont aujourd'hui pas bus
pas pas voiture non plus puisque c'est
des des tout petits trajets qui peuvent
s'insérer dans dans dans la vie
quotidienne des gens et donc on a
discuté avec Renault qui est venu nous
parler de de ses véhicules électriques
et puis de cette ambition je crois que
c'est Renault aussi qui a eu cette
ambition de de se dire je veux apporter
plus que la que que de la vente de
véhicule apporter un service derrière
c'est surtout ça qui nous a intéressé
c'est ce service là euh qui vous l'avez
compris par la description qui est assez
qui offre un maximum de liberté du coup
c'est un projet 100 % Renault ou la
commaglo s'inscrit alors on s'est
inscrit on 100 % Renault c'est c'est
Renault qui l'a développé on s'est porté
notre territoire s'est porté site
expérimental donc c'est un partenariat
c'est une expérimentation pendant un an
euh euh qui nous a comme comme j'ai pu
vous le dire qui nous a fortement
intéressé donc là c'est expérimenté
pendant un an d'autres villes
agglomération se sont montré intéressés
c'est sûr enfin c'està notre service est
intéressant je pense queon a
effectivement des villes qui qui toquent
à la porte mais pour le moment nous
sommes en expérimentation donc à 50 ans
voilà donc je ne peux pas vous dire
alors ce matin donc l'agence a été
ouverte au public vous avez déjà eu
beaucoup de monde je je n'ai pas eu de
retour depuis mais on a quand même pas
eu eu pas mal de monde au bout une heure
on avait déjà inscrit une quinzaine de
clients donc ils attend et vous savez un
peu le profil justement de ces clients
est-ce que c'est des gens qui vont de
dans 50 en ieline ou qui cherch à faire
d'autres pour aller travailler voilà il
y a plusieurs profils en fait de clients
il y a des clients qui habitent sur
place et qui se déplacent par exemple le
soir pour aller au cinéma ou pour aller
à une activité sportive on a aussi
certaines personnes qui viennent en
transport en commun à des heures creuses
qui n'ont pas forcément le bus à
proximité donc qui qui vont prendre le
tzy on a a plusieurs profils on a aussi
quelques étudiants c'est assez varié
hein en tout cas nous pour notre part
nous sommes aller dans les rues de
Saint-Quentin allit demander aux gens
s'il savaient ce qu'était la la Ty on va
voir si elle elle est populaire une côte
de popular on va mesurer ça allez on
écoute
oui c'est la voiture électrique là que
qui en ESS sur le sa-quentin je crois
non pas du tout qu'est-ce que ça
pourrait être d'après vous
euh la Ty quelque chose en rapport avec
l'informatique enfin pas l'informatique
mais genre je sais pas Twitter la tzy
oui je sais ce que c'est et alors c'est
quoi bah c'est une voiture à une place
une petite voiture électrique je crois
que c'est Renault qui est le fabricant
bah c'est la voiture de chez Renault
voilà après je sais pas les tarifs ou
autes mais j'en ai devant chez moi ah
ben bien sûr c'est une petite voiture
électrique qu'est-ce que vous en savez
de plus ah ben je l'ai essayé voilà très
bien c'est un petit un petit t carar
façon petite voiture et pour faire des
petits déplacements je trouve ça très
sympa ça se garde très facilement et
puis c'est très écologique bon je vois
quand même des fois des jeunes qui
ouvrent les portes qui se mettent dedans
pour pour essayer donc bon je me dis
après au fil du temps je sais pas
comment ça va elle va être quoi voilà on
voit que c'est assez populaire aussi
cette cette dame qui parle un peu des
des l'incivilité est-ce qu'il y a des
incivilités on a nous a remonté quelques
cas c'est pas dramatique ce qu'on a
trouvé surtout c'est que les les clients
testeurs là les 200 clients testurs
étaient très solidaires se sont
appropriés le service il y en a même qui
le nettoyé il y en a qui ont fait des
poèmes sur le véhicule donc on a senti
vraiment une une communauté c'est
vraiment ça ça paraît être le service
appartient à chacun en fait à chacun des
m communauté c'est étonnant qu vraiment
on a senti une communauté des gens qui
qui échangeaient qui après parlaient sur
le blog parce qu'on avait un blog pour
les leur faire échanger en fait leurs
impressions et il se disaient oH je t'ai
vu la dernière fois avec le tzy numéro
18 et cetera c'est assez il y en a même
qui qui ont lavé les véhicules enfin
c'est c'est assez et ça pourrait donner
des idées à la communauté
d'agglomération de pouvoir en louer pour
les propres déplacements des agents
alors c'est oui ça nous donne des idées
mais c'est pas c'est pas tout à fait le
même principe parce que là le réserver à
des agents c'est ça nécessite de garder
le véhicule pour les agents donc il sera
pas en libre service la grande
difficulté c'est de le rendre en libre
service euh parce que nous on
l'utilisera pas toute la journée et
c'est cet outil là c'est fait aussi pour
faire circuler le minimum de véhicules
et faire le minimum le maximum de
déplacement donc oui on a des idées sur
sur ce type d'outil qui est comme le
disait la dame c'est un petit peu
écologique quand même hein c'est la
voiture électrique mais on n'est pas sur
on n'est pas tout à fait sur le même
service quoi donc on réfléchit oui
effectivement sur ce sujet là alors la
tis est présentée cette semaine c'est
peut-être pas un hasard parce que c'est
la Semaine de la
mobilité à SaintQuentin en Yv il y a eu
une enquête industive du Syndicat des
transports franiliens qui dans cette
enquête il ressort notamment que 70 %
des déplacements se font de banlieu à à
banlieu euh et certainement au sein
aussi d'une agglomération comme sa-
Quentin il y a beaucoup de de
déplacements qui se font de d'habitation
entre Reise comment vous essayez
d'inciter les salariés des entreprises à
utiliser des transports soit la tisy
mais aussi le vélo les bus à pied ben
c'est c'est un peu le but de la semaine
de la mobilité
c'est tout à fait donc c'est un petit
peu semaine la semaine de la mobilité
c'est quelque chose qu'on a renouvelé ça
fait quand même 3 4 ans qu' que l'on
fait ça le but de la manœuvre c'est de
donner de l'information le maximum
d'information aux usagers quel qu'il
soit alors notamment sur les entreprises
puisquon a là cette année on a encore
fait sur 12 sites d'entreprise notre
territoire on donne de l'information aux
salariés de toute l'évolution du réseau
de transport on est un peu à l'écoute
aussi de de des remonté qui nous font et
on essaie d'améliorer année par année
l'offre de
transport justement au niveau des bus
est-ce qu'il y a des entreprises qui
vous remontent des demandes
particulières bien sûr parce que c'est
souvent la la grosse problématique hein
tout à fait donc c'est pour ça qu'on les
suit donc dans le cadre des plans de
déplacement inter entreprise qu'on a eu
l'occasion d'évoquer on essaie d'avoir
un suivi des entreprises pour pour tout
simplement parce que une entreprise ça
vit ça évolue les horaires le nombre
d'emploi d'emplois le nombre de de les
les les les emplois évoluent aussi donc
on essaie de se caler parfaitement à la
demande donc on a besoin de de cette
source d'information pour répondre on
essaie de répondre au mieux possible
notment avec Renault on a fait on a fait
de l'adaptation chaque année on fait de
l'adaptation ça évolue euh tous les ans
donc c'est un travail qu'il faudrait
renouveler et puis essayer de à travers
la semaine de la mobilité de faire
parler ces gens parce que comment on le
voit sur tzy il y a quand même un retour
qui est assez favorable au moins on est
à l'écoute et on apporte des rép les
gens qu'on interviewé c'est qu' ils
connaissaient et ça av l'air de les de
les intéresser une dernière question
Corine paquet alors si on veut acheter
on peut acheter la tzie aussi oui on
peut acheter la T est-ce que vous ne
fournissez pas vous de Born de
rechargement comme autolive peut fournir
des peut servir de bornes de
rechargement à sa petite voiture
électrique non nous nous n'avons pas
besoin de bornes pour recharger les
teezy déjà quelqu'un qui veut acheter la
T un particulier qui veut acheter une
tszie peut la brancher comme sur une
prise aspir c'est toujours le problème
quand il habite en appartement pour
faire courir un fil depuis le 3è étage
mais là en fait la communauté
d'agglomération je pense va réfléchir
aussi à un plan de voouà non ce qu'on ce
qu'on a voulu c'est VO c'est
plôt les véhicules parce que là c'est
c'est c'est un service particulier qui
est qui est proposé par Renault donc le
le but de la manœuvre c'est si on se
mettait à installer une borne électrique
faut pas que ça soit exclusivement
réservé à la TiSi mais ouvert à toute
toute population même des gens qui
seraient propriéaires d'un véhicule
électrique donc là pour l'instant il y
en a pas sur la donc pour l'instant il y
en a pas c'est en réflexion Alce qu'on
on attend de voir un petit peu les
résultats de de cette expérimentation
notamment voir si ça marche visiblement
ça marche mais c'est surt de voir là où
il y a le plus de flux pour pouvoir si
jamais on décidait d'implanter ces
bornes d'avoir un maximum de de
fonctionnement un fonctionnement optimal
dès le départ quoi d'accord parce que
mettre des bandes partout c'est bien
mais qu'elle soit utilisé c'est encore
mieux en tout cas nous sommes preneurs
et nous montrons déjà que nous sommes
motivésord est en train de se signer sur
le plateau télé déjà peut-être une suite
à alors merci en tout cas à vous deêtre
venu sur ce plateau dans quelques
instants on va retrouver Maxime pour sa
chronique innovation vous allez voir ça
êre surprenant surprenant mais d'abord
direction est en cours la Fédération
Française d'échecs s'est installée sur
la commune ce qui promet l'avenue de
Grand Maître
reportage après Montpellier et un bref
passage par Manille amau la Fédération
Française deschècs a finalement pris ses
quartiers à lancour dans la commanderie
des Templiers samedi un déménagement
prévu depuis 2005 pour Henry Carvallo
président de la Fédération
l'implantation sur un site templier et
symboliquement intéressant on est très
heureux d'être dans une commanderie
templière vous savez que les échecs sont
un sport mais mais sont aussi très
culturel et et sont venus d'Orient et je
suis sû que les Templiers ont contribué
au au passage de du jeu d'échec du monde
oriental au monde de l'Occident médiéval
l'objectif de ce déplacement est de se
rapprocher de Paris donc des
institutions et d'éventuels partenaires
voire sponsors évidemment 50 ansbline
profitera de la la présence de la
Fédération des collaborations sont déjà
envisagées avec la base de loisirs et
pourquoi pas d'autres fédérations
sportives du territoire comme le golf et
le cyclisme autre terrain de
prédilection pour la Fédération
Française d'échec les écoles aujourd'hui
c'est plus spécifiquement sur hlencour
qui a une un projet pédagogique qui
implique l'ensemble des des écoles de la
ville d'élancour donc il y a des cours
d'échec qui sont donnés dans chacune
chacun des 16 groupes scolaires de de la
ville encour ce serait une bonne idée
que d'essayer de redimensionner ça à la
à l'échelle du territoire de à l'échelle
nationale la fédération compte 60000
licenciers événement de taille dans le
milieu le championnat de France des
équipes le Top 12 est prévu pour l'an
prochain dans les locaux de la chapelle
de la Villedieu